you told me a story once about the worst
I have a worst breakup I think of all
time and it was one of those breakups
that's like will spring up and you're
and you're a hit like it's like wait
what where where was I like it's almost
like you checked out of a movie and then
all of a sudden like the main characters
like holding a bloody weapon oh wait
wait wait like what hey miss I'm asleep
and then I'm just trying to keep my mind
off of it
so I go and do a show I'm gonna do like
a live show at UCB and then see like my
phone is ringing a bunch of like oh
there's my dad was like dad calling me I
like other you Sunday night you never
want to parent phone call in the evening
or any day no yeah yeah yeah if it's
beyond the text I'm nervous
my parents are in their seventies any
phone call I'm like oh
yeah but it but then it's I was like I
found a petunia my mom called me three
times in the day to ask if I got my
birthday flowers by the way weird that
my mom sent me flowers on my birthday
yeah it goes like a Secretary's day or
something like thank you mom I love them
but it's also like sunflowers I'm gonna
throw you this way I get a Valentine's
Day card from my mother although that's
sweet is it ish so I've bummed out I get
this call from my dad and I pick it up
and he's like oh you're um are you know
you're my father your grandfather has
passed away as like Oh God so bad day
bad day yeah that day and I go back to
my my apartment and I'm like I'm just
like no one's there I'm like I'm like I
gotta move and I got this dog I got this
dog it wasn't even a dog that I wanted
like it was a dog that was given to me
as a gift and you've heard this thing I
never give a dog as a gift there's a
very good reason for that
it's a terrible gift so I get this dog
as a gift the first time I introduced to
him my girlfriend who broke up with me
she's like come into the bedroom I got a
surprise as I go exciting open the door
there's a dog and he's pissed all over
the bed like he's nervous
so like spirit he's a big fan he's
nervous
of course you know look I was on best
week ever my level that's at that bro
that's how our relationship started it
went downhill from there was the most
violent dog the most abusive dog like
any time we had friends over the house
just like would like rip up their feet
like and like you bring them to the dog
park and people would be like one glance
pretty on a place to get this dog
running and you know that wrong I go
like this and then like I felt like I
had to deal with this dog and it's like
terrible diarrhea you're like diarrhea
in New York City with a dog is awful cuz
I had to clean that out fin it's I
haven't got awful times with this dog
this dog was the worst and now my
girlfriend has left me my grandfather's
died I'm in my apartment alone with this
dog and that's great and I'm laying on
my bed I'm just like all God oh this is
the worst everything is bad and the dog
jumps on the bed and he comes over to me
and for the first time the dog is like
sweet you know any and anything oh my
gosh is he gonna feel your sadness she
knows it and and he's gonna comfort me
in this moment like he's calm you know
barking it comes over and it gets right
in my face and like I kind of like pick
my head up and in that moment the dogs
either got a long snout he's goes BAM it
breaks my nose breaks my nose I'm in the
bed blood is pouring down my face thanks
so much Paul you're one of the funniest
people I know my gosh Pete is so good
I'll get a good chick all right did it
work yeah I'm there what are we gonna
say I was gonna say I'll see you at
brunch